this is a really interesting uh sign a
whole bunch of Republicans who won their
2022 primaries wiped
uh mentions of failed former president
Donald Trump from their websites after
their primary as they reset their
campaigns for the general election in
November this signals an arguably
significant change within the Republican
electorate at least as far as the
candidates are perceiving so let's talk
about it there's a good Daily Beast
article by Sam Brody who's a
congressional reporter which points out
and is titled Republican candidates
strip abortion and Trump connections
from their campaign websites these
Republicans have made a calculation they
made the calculation during the primary
among the Republican electorate it's
good to play up our connection to Trump
and our our support of Donald Trump once
they won their primary their view
changed and they said okay for the
general election electorate I am now
better off removing mentions of Donald
Trump and I think when we look at
exactly who these candidates are it will
start to make a lot of sense and we're
going to link to this article and you
can check it out uh and I'm getting a
paywall and let me just see if I can
deal with that so that we can actually
look at the article that popped up all
of a sudden and because of clarity I
really want to uh here we go okay right
after Beau Heinz won a crowded primary
from Congress in North Carolina
a visitor to the campaign website would
immediately find his declaration that he
was 100 percent pro-life and 100 percent
pro-trump pretty clear
a click away was a section focused on
life and family which professed Heinz
position that life begins at conception
naturally the first thing greeting any
visitor to the site was the grinning
face of trump and it is all gone gone
gone
and the article points out that all of
that stuff all of those invocations and
images of Donald Trump they've all been
removed except for one apparently
photoshopped image with Heinz in the
section on border security this is not
the first person who did this The Daily
Beast reviewed a bunch of different
websites for 2022 Republican candidates
and found that at least five house
Republican candidates in Battleground
districts completely wiped or scrubbed
mentions of trump or the 2020 election
from their websites or social media
right after winning the primaries at
least seven removed or significantly
modified language about abortion on
their websites over the summer
at least three have scrubbed their
online pages of trump that includes
Blake masters of Arizona Mehmet Oz of
Pennsylvania Tiffany Smiley of
Washington and at least two did the same
for abortion Blake Masters and Adam
laxalt so as the article says generally
it's uncommon to see Cam that it
significantly changed Platforms in
branding during the course of a campaign
some of them are saying well we just
redirect we just redesigned the website
that's all we did others are saying well
we reshuffled the content to other
places but we know exactly what is going
on here there is a recognition among
many of these Republican candidates that
number one the Hardline anti-abortion
positions are out of step with the
American public we know that
all polling shows us that over the last
50 years what we call the Roe v Wade era
over the period of the Roe v Wade era
the country has moved in the direction
of abortion being legal to those who
want it in most cases and this really
came to a head with the Supreme Court's
reversal of Roe v Wade with guaranteed
abortion as a right in most cases to
women
this is now causing a problem for some
Republicans and the way some of them are
dealing with it is getting rid of the
hardcore anti-choice language from their
websites but there's a second bigger
recognition as well the guy that will
help you win among the Republican
electorate may actually hurt you in the
general election and we're talking of
course of Donald Trump this is to some
degree a change from previous years you
know we often laugh about Trump takes
credit for his endorsement record and
that record really isn't quite as good
as he claims it to be but the truth is
that it was pretty good for a while and
it no longer is seen as the sort of
unabashed advantage that it was at one
point we will see how these folks do in
November uh and then we will see what
that means for 2024.